now to the conflict in Yemen where the
US is in the background as well while
two of its main allies in the Middle
East have gone their separate ways the
u.s. is part of a Saudi Arabia led
Coalition in Yemen that is fighting
Houthi rebels who are in turn backed by
Tehran Iran while the conflict has taken
a devastating toll on the civilians in
Yemen and just last weekend the de facto
capital for the United Nations backed
government in Aden was all but taken
over by separatists the former capital
sana fell to Houthi rebels five years
ago the United Arab Emirates was a part
of the Saudi coalition supporting the
government but has now backed out and we
should note that the separatists now in
Aden were trained by the UAE I hope
you're still with me I want to bring in
now an expert on the region Elizabeth
Kendall as she is a senior research
fellow at Pennbrook at college of the
University of Oxford and she joins us
from Geneva a very good evening
professor as you know better than
anybody else this is such an intricate
story can you untangle it for us tease
it out for us and bring it back to the
basics so we can understand what is
going on in Yemen well essentially we
have three rival political groupings
each of whom wish now to rule Yemen we
have the internationally recognized
government of president Hadi and he
himself is based in Riyadh he has
however got a temporary capital in Aden
which is as you say just been overrun by
the second grouping which is the
southern transitional council and they
want separatists southern state and then
of course we have the Houthis they are
in the actual capital of Yemen Sanaa so
we've got three different capitals with
three different Parliament's and backed
by three different international powers
Iran UAE and Saudi so it is a bit of a
mess to say the least I mean and as if
there's
conflict wasn't complicated enough there
now has been in fighting among anti
Houthi forces that's right the forces
backed by the United Arab Emirates over
the weekend took over the southern
capital Aden and they ultimately would
like to have their own state so they are
coming to blows with the forces of the
formally recognized president Hedy and
it's very unclear how this might end
right now sings a calm in the port city
of Aden in the south but they could
easily escalate again because the
southern forces are refusing to withdraw
from the military positions that they've
taken and although they've agreed to a
ceasefire and talks the president heard
he is saying well I won't have talks
unless you withdraw from your military
positions first so it's still very
volatile but that said Leila and I
should say that the leadership at the
level of the UAE leader Mohammed bin
Zayed and the Saudi leader King Salman
and the Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman
they're very unlikely to fall out
publicly they're going to paper over
these cracks and put a good cosmetic
face on it this this is such a nice
segue because I really want us to focus
on on that and take our conversation to
that Saudi UAE alliance because Abu
Dhabi's crown prince has was in Saudi
this week to calm tensions and the
optics were you know there's no trouble
here
we want all the warring parties to come
to the negotiating table but what is the
likelihood of the warring tables that
putting down their arms and engaging in
a political process and were you
convinced by the UAE leader trying to
smooth over the differences that have
arisen with Saudi well that's a very
potent question in fact the statement
that came out of their meeting in Mecca
on Monday was very general it talked
about brotherly love and mutual interest
and shared goals but it didn't go into
any of the detail about the future shape
of Yemen
and what both of their end goals are
inside that country and although it's
very unlikely that the leaders
themselves will fall out indeed they
haven't fallen out they don't have
control over their forces on the ground
we've already seen that because they've
already come to blows
once in 2018 twice in 2017 and now much
more seriously in Aden so I think that
horse has bolted what will be
interesting will be to see what happens
next
because if Saudi Arabia who backs the
hurdy government decides to use force to
ask for Southerners from their military
positions then I think we will have
another war inside a war how much is
this all due to the fact that the Trump
administration is still exercising this
maximum pressure campaign on Iran has
that inevitably pushed the UAE to
withdraw from Yemen and turn its
attention towards managing those
tensions with Iran that have arisen now
I think the UAE has been planning to
exit the very unpopular and very
expensive war against the Houthis in the
north for some time and in one sense you
could say that the Trump
administration's maximum pressure policy
gave it a bit of an excuse because it
does now have in place thousands and
thousands of troops that it has
recruited and trained across the South
of Yemen and that appears to be whether
it's real interests lie it doesn't want
to be involved in a very unpopular war
in the north that has driven populations
in the West to criticize it so heavily
so it's going to now leave that to Saudi
Arabia mm-hmm
very precarious situation indeed for
Riyadh Elizabeth Kendall a senior
research fellow in Arabic and Islamic
Studies at England's Penn Brook College
thank you so much for sharing your
expertise with us thanks for having me